- My name is Chris Joynt.
I'm from Securiti AI, an AWS partner,
and I'm going to talk to
you today a little bit
about how leveraging Graph
Insights can help you turbocharge
your deployment of Amazon Q for business.
Now, we all know, of course,
AI is disrupting everything.
It's disrupting how work is
done, how we build value,
how we deliver value.
I think a lot of us would agree,
if we've been in the
IT sector for a while,
we've probably never seen
anything like this before, right?
More hype, more
capability, more, you know,
everything happening kind of all at once.
I also do think it's fair to say, however,
that the kind of ability to capture value
is still catching up to what models can do
and what AI can do these days, right?
And that's one of the reasons why Amazon Q
is such an effective solution, right?
It's kind of built to
very easily help you,
you know, sit on top of your data
and deliver value to your users.
And it's also secure
and private by design,
which is important
because one of the things
that's a major roadblock
for a lot of organizations
that want to roll out AI is
concerns about data security.
That's the number one roadblock
for anybody trying to roll out AI.
So Amazon Q is secure
and private by design
to help alleviate that, right?
And what it'll do is
it'll respect identities
and roles and permissions,
ensuring that personalized interactions
are based on the user's actual data access
that they have, right?
So Amazon Q does respect permissions,
and it also offers data
privacy in the sense that
Amazon is not taking
your data and using it,
you know, to improve their models
or storing it anywhere, right?
Your data stays private.
And Amazon Q, however,
makes it very, very easy
to search data, right?
The speed and power and scale of AI,
it's just different than a
human user going somewhere
and kind of search and destroy method,
going to different data sources
and trying to query them.
You know, when you have
AI that can crawl deeply
through your data on a very
granular level, you know,
and do it, you know, at every query.
What will happen, it'll surface
whatever it finds, right?
So it's sort of a double-edged sword
where you can very easily,
if you don't have things,
you know, tightly controlled,
you can very easily have
unintended data exposure, right?
So you could have an
employee say, you know,
I want salary information
for employees in the US
or what companies are
we evaluating for M&A,
or could I get social security numbers
for our employees, right?
If you don't have your
underlying data structure,
you know, properly permissioned
and knowledge of where all
of your sensitive data is
and all of your policies in order,
you could very easily expose that
with the speed and power
that AI gives to any user, right?
The problem with that, however,
is data states are
incredibly complex, right?
Especially when we're
talking about getting down
to the file level where we
need to have intelligence
and we need to have control, right?
At a deep file level.
We're not talking about securing AI
by securing a data system.
We're talking about we
need to have intelligence
at the file level.
And that's incredibly complex, right?
When we look at the size
of, you know, a data state,
it could be tens or hundreds
of billions of files,
you know, hundreds of millions of tables,
thousands of streams, and you know,
petabytes upon petabytes of data.
We actually have one
large enterprise customer
that generates just in
logs in a given day,
you know, unstructured
multistructured logs, in one day,
more than a petabyte of data, right?
So it's just absolutely absurd,
you know, numbers there and
you have different file types,
you know, different sensitivity
levels of different data,
different types of
sensitive data, you know,
different regulations that
that data might be beholden to,
permission structures, policies.
It's very complex, right?
So what we do and how we help
is we actually take your data, right?
And you know, kind of scan through it
on a deeply granular level, right?
And extract from the file level
thousands of pieces of metadata
that we can then associate back in a graph
that will kind of show
you all of the connections
between things in your data, right?
So you see connections
between users and groups
and permissions and policies and data.
You'll see the geographies and the,
you know, regulations
that they're beholden to
kind of all visualized in a graph
that makes it very, very easy to see
where there might be issues, right?
So this allows us to sort of give you
a deep level of intelligence
that gives you sensitive
data protection, right?
And a policy enforcement layer
so you can write policy against that data.
It gives you a very granular
data access intelligence
that helps you to identify
any overpermissioning
that might be problematic or,
you know, where you know you
have permissioning issues
that might not be in line
with regulations, right?
And it also gives you the
ability to remediate any
of those issues and make
your underlying data safe
for the usage with AI, right?
And we'll do this across all
of your data sources, right?
Not just data in AWS,
but data across your
entire environment, right?
So this is what we do.
We kind of build this
graph structure for you
and kind of auto-populate
this graph from the metadata
that we're able to extract from
the file level of your data.
Okay?
And then what we'll also
do is we can via API,
you know, push out, you
know, policy recommendations
and things of that nature to
external systems and apps.
So if you wanted to connect with, say,
like a CNAPP or a SOC
for security purposes,
or use that data command API,
I'll show you a way that we
can use that with AI as well.
So how do we work with Amazon Q, right?
We're sort of a parallel
companion solution
for Amazon Q, right?
Where what Amazon Q is going
to do is it's going to,
you know, index data
from your data systems.
And like I said before,
respect the permissioning
and everything that you have in that data,
it's going to respect the labels
and the policies on how to deal with data
given those labels, right?
So what Securiti is going to do
is we're going to do the
classification and the labeling.
We're going to enforce
privileged data access.
We're going to reduce data exposures
and also removal of old,
redundant, obsolete or trivial data
that could be causing security issues or,
you know, reducing the
quality of AI outputs, right?
So what we'll do is we'll kind of
inspect those data systems,
show you insights in our graph,
and then push remediations
back into those data systems
so that Amazon Q can then
safely index that data
for business usage, okay?
So let's go into some of
those in detail, right?
So I said we're going to do
data classification and labeling first.
That's kind of the most important piece.
At that file level,
we have more than 400 classifiers
that will classify different
types of sensitive data,
and then give you the policy engine
to label that data as you wish.
So you could say something like,
for executives only, right?
Or something like that that gives Amazon Q
the information that it needs
to properly handle that data, right?
After we do classification and labeling,
then we can talk about removal
of ROT data or stale data.
This is actually a bigger
thing than you might think.
So ROT data can destroy
trust and accuracy, right?
So with duplicate fields, you know,
copies of files all over the place,
you know, AI might not know,
that's going to confuse AI,
it's going to throw off
your results, right?
It also gives you kind of a
poor employee experience, right?
And we know that people are very brutal
when it comes to whether they trust AI
and they're going to adopt it or not.
If they don't get the
answer they're looking for
after two or three times,
or they get some junk,
they're very quick to write off AI
and kind of move on to another one,
so it has a big impact on adoption.
But also there can be security issues
that are caused by this kind
of redundant and stale data,
copies of things all over the place,
might have different security settings,
might have different access privileges,
and create kind of a loophole
that you need to clean up, right?
So one of the things that we'll do
is we'll identify and
remove redundant data.
This alone can have a huge, huge ROI
that can fund, you know, your
whole project to begin with,
just the removal of stale data.
Next, you know, we'll
talk about preventing
inappropriate data access, right?
So this shift from structured
to unstructured data,
you know,
we have to now govern things like emails,
documents, chats, things of that nature.
It's a bit different than
the structured data world.
And you know, we need
granular access intelligence
across billions and
billions of files, right?
And the ability to apply
context aware and conditional
attribute based access controls, right?
So here's just a visualization of,
you know, what we'll show
you in the graph, right?
You can see a piece of
financial data, you know,
and the specific policies
and the specific permissions, right?
That's mapped to it, right?
The entitlements that are mapped to it
against a certain piece of financial data,
you'll see that across, you know,
your entire data state
giving you the ability
to remediate data access issues
and over permissioning issues
that could lead to inappropriate
data access via AI, right?
And then, okay,
so once we have things kind of cleaned up
from a data access standpoint,
we've done our
classification and labeling,
we've done ROT data removal,
then we talk about, you
know, what about fresh data,
fresh data coming in?
Securiti data command center can act
as sort of the policy engine, right?
To validate incoming data
before it's indexed by Q, right?
So we can consult the graph
via the data command graph API
and say, "Should I index this, yes or no?"
Right?
Is this safe based on how
this data is classified,
what sensitive data might be in there,
and what policies we need to apply to it?
Should I index this, yes or no?
So this is a way that we can
kind of, on a continual basis,
you know, operationalize
the data AI security
and keep feeding Amazon
Q fresh, safe data.
All right.
So I just wanted to point
out real quick that,
you know, this layer, this
information governance layer,
this information governance layer
is the foundation of the
Gartner AI TRiSM stack.
I'm sorry, it's covered up here
by a mysterious white box for some reason,
but that's a foundational capability.
But this is, you know,
kind of very simple four step process.
We've helped a lot of customers through
that have gone through this path.
You know, first detect, classify
and label sensitive data
per your enterprise policies,
reduce old data usage, ROT data usage,
and then you can start to layer on
least privileged data access and then,
you know, scaling usage with fresh data
and kind of, you know, ongoing
data sanitization, right?
So why use Securiti and our graph?
To enable the safe adoption
of Amazon Q for business,
prevent unintended sharing of data,
you know, with intelligent risk detection
and automated remediation,
improve the quality of AI
response by reducing ROT data,
and the ability to secure all your data
and AI across environments, okay?
So those are kind of three
reasons to use Securiti
along with Amazon Q for business.
And just wanted to throw it out there.
This same process works the same way
right alongside Amazon Quick Suite,
if any of you are considering
Amazon Quick Suite
to build AI agent applications, okay?
So feel free to come stop
by the booth, we're in 1966,
or you can kind of scan the QR
code here to request a demo.
We've got all kinds of collateral
and demos at the booth as well.
And I also have, I can show you,
we have another product that goes along
with the data command graph,
our Gencore AI Securiti solution
that will protect data in motion, right?
By kind of detecting policy
violations across an AI system
as data moves across the system
without requiring you to
influence the behavior
of an AI model, kind of protecting it
by restricting the flow
of data across the system.
So we'll be demoing that as well,
and I'm excited about that.
That should be available soon as the MCP
for any of you who are building things
in Bedrock and Agent Core.
So we'll be showing that
at the booth as well.
But that's all I had today.